Charlie it's Oh Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool right something is stuck on
my mind and it is not coming off I have
heard so many people telling me that
this is the best game ever and I am I I
haven't got it yet
it's so badly stuck on my mind you can
see it it is it is it is it the best
game ever
I mean seriously I have watched so many
videos about this repeatedly as well and
I just burn I don't understand why I
didn't pre-order it or something I am
gonna do my absolute best to get this
game tomorrow because I just can't take
this anymore
I just cannot this might actually be
making me a little bit ill I mean
speaking of speaking of Nintendo on the
8th of December
my Nintendo Wii will be one years old
and you are all invited to his birthday
party oh why why haven't I don't you
yeah why why why wasn't already people
are saying it's better than Ocarina of
Time I mean it just doesn't make sense
like my head is just kind of going Mario
Mario why do you do this to me oh you
see when you look at it like that I
really am a loser aren't I